oui mais ivan bonjour et merci être en
direct avec nous alors tout d'abord
quelle est la situation dans votre
hôpital à oloron sainte marie
bonjour la situation dans mon hôpital
est un peu semblable à tous les tous les
services et tous les hôpitaux de france
c'est à dire qu'il ya des périodes vente
nature d'autres services et d'autres
recettes libère un petit peu mais les
plâtres envie que reprise par de
nouveaux malades vous sentez une plus
forte tension ces derniers jours avec
justement cette crainte d'une voilà de
l'apparition de variantes de kobe 19 qui
s'y multiplient dans l'hexagone mais
alacrité est partout en effet avec le
variant pour l'instant on est on n'est
pas touché mais la crainte est est bien
présente en effet alors dans quelle
mesure justement cela at il des
conséquences sur votre travail est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les soignants sont amenés
à faire plus d'heures dans les hôpitaux
alors les soignants sont amenés comme
depuis le début la crise et comme avant
cette crise sanitaire est à dire à venir
remplacer en cas de maladie de certains
de nos collègues ou en cas d'atteinte de
d'effectifs parce que l'on est en
sous-effectif donc ça change
dis donc ça va changer qui a plus de 2
de personnel à quatre doigts depuis des
mois est ce que certaines interventions
opérations chirurgicales ont dû être
reportés ou annulés
ces derniers jours dans mon hôpital dans
votre hôpital exactement le pas
spécialement pour les attend soit encore
un peu des meubles j'ai envie de dire
mais
pour les sciences la semaine alors on
est toujours en couvre-feu avancé à 18
heures dans toute la france on sait que
beaucoup de scientifiques demande
réclame même un confinement nationale
pour essayer de contrôler la situation
est ce que voilà c'est une mesure que le
gouvernement devrait appliquer le plus
tôt possible selon vous la question est
difficile de refaire un autre
confinement peut en effet bouclé la
propagation de virus après un troisième
confinement belle sera d impact et
psychologique dramatique on le voit
aujourd'hui les consultations pour des
problèmes psychiatriques psychologiques
augmente énormément dans les services
d'urgence les les gens n'en peuvent plus
donc il ya une balance qui doit être
bien bien réglé et c'est compliqué la
décision est compliqué vraiment ce qui
m'inquiète les consultations
psychologiques heures dans les
prochaines semaines vous criez pas être
débordé comme lors de la 1er vague il ya
presque un an maintenant le problème est
toujours le même et que en fait on
manque de lits donc on sera débordé si
on continue de fermer des lits qui est
toujours le cas on a encore 300 à 400 me
qui vont terminer sur l'hôpital bichat
il y avait ça en tête la problématique
c'est que on fait des confidences certes
parce que l'hôpital stature mais il
stature parce qu'on continue de fermer
des lits donc à un moment donné il faut
arrêter de faire ces fermetures de lits
et ré ouvrir des lignes ont donné la
possibilité de soigner les gens qu'on
n'a pas aujourd'hui réouvrir délit cela
implique plus de personnel soignant au
niveau national également bien sûr
qu'est ce qu'on demandait ce que le
figure avait alayli sauf que c'est
illusoire
aujourd'hui on ne le voit pas du tout
très bien en tout cas merci beaucoup
noémie ban j'aimerais en plus d'être
intervenu sur rt france ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes président du
collectif antérieures gens c'est
infirmière aux urgences d'oloron 1
sainte honorine